Uncanny X-Men.
It'll take all of your mutant powers to defeat Magneto.
And welcome to the Nostalgia Black Friday Special.
For an unlimited time only, we're bringing
you the biggest savings in podcast history.
Over 250 episodes of our show completely free.
And as a special doorbuster.
For our Patreon subscribers, they are getting this episode
on Thanksgiving.
You too can save, not your money, but your time when you join our Patreon
and get access to certain episodes hours earlier.
So stampede over now and pay for your discount.
And listen to this episode again on Cyber Monday for double the savings.
And I'm Mike.
Can I speak to your manager?
That sounds like the perfect kind of Black Friday lingo to continue this conversation, Joe.
Thanks. That's me.
I'm Joe. Yeah, we're recording.
I'm Sean.
There's no better way to get into an episode on Black Friday than to talk about all the savings
of your own time when you don't have to play the game anymore.
You can just listen to our review
of Uncanny X-Men on the NES.
I've been waiting all Thanksgiving for this.
Like I ate some food because my family made me.
Um, but now I'm here and I'm ready to spend some cash.
Yeah. I mean, I hate when I have to work right after Thanksgiving on Black Friday, but here I am.
Joe, do you have any actual experience in retail on Black Friday?
I do. I do.
Uh, I used to work at Sears.
Uh, shout out to Sears and my old Sears crew.
Uh, and I actually liked it.
I actually, oh, I loved working at Sears.
I just made commission and I loved working on Black Friday because I made commission.
So it was, uh, usually a pretty fruitful day.
How old are you?
I know, right? You know, this was in the forties.
I just don't, but that's why I loved it.
Listen, that's why I love it.
Not to make this a Sears episode,
but you get me going about Sears and I'll go on.
That's why I loved it because in, you know,
in 2014 or whenever it was 2013, when I was working there, nobody goes to Sears anymore.
Yeah. So, and all my friends work there.
So we just hang out.
There were no customers. And then we get
like one or two customers a day.
I sold appliances. So that was still enough commission to make more
than I had made in other part-time jobs.
And then I would just hang out with my friends the rest of
the day. No customers.
Plus the fact that we made straight commission meant that they couldn't tell
us to do anything else because we weren't getting paid to do any other tasks other than to sell.
So it was great. It's like you were a mutant who had mutant powers to sell appliances, to sell washing machines.
I'm an ex-employee and an ex-salesman.
Ooh. Oh yeah.
Ex-salesman. The uncanny ex-salesman.
Yeah. Yeah. It was uncanny that I worked at Sears.
Mike, what? Well, I have a question about, about X-Men.
Sure. Um, the price, you can get it for $12 on eBay.
Um, no, this is actually a real question about nerdy things, but is, is uncanny X-Men like
the original like name of the, the, the property?
Is that like a, a section of X-Men-dom?
Yes. It's a section.
It's a section of, of the X-Men.
So the uncanny X-Men thing is, uh, is the original, like the very first issue of X-Men, the creation of the X-Men, if you will, did not have them be known as the uncanny X-Men.
It was just the X-Men.
So what makes like, what, what, what makes uncanny X-Men different?
Come on, you're, you know this.
Yeah. Well, no. So it's like weird because there's also like what's giant size X-Men too, because that's like also a very, uh, in demand issue of the X-Men series.
But it's like weird, like in the canon, is that a different run of X-Men?
Like what's going on? Basically, they change the names of these things when, um, when like new characters are introduced or, uh, so for instance, like the uncanny X-Men, I believe started with like issue, uh, like maybe 67 or 94.
One of those two, um, they started just referring to them as that instead, kind of like how, you know, the Spider-Man is the amazing Spider-Man, but then there's also web of Spider-Man and spectacular Spider-Man, right?
It's like the differences is like the story that there's kind of stories that they're telling and who the audience is for.
But then like giant size X-Men was like an entire, uh, new idea of X-Men.
Like, uh, that one had like now Wolverines with the X-Men and stuff like that instead of being like a Hulk villain.
Um, and they're all like seven feet tall.
Uh, in the, oh, I get you.
Yeah. No, no, no. It's just giant size because it was like 64 pages or something like that.
Oh, okay. All right.
So canonically uncanny X-Men is no, like, is not on some different universe than like what had come before it.
Right. Exactly. Yeah.
It's just, they just kind of started branding it differently.
Think of uncanny X-Men no different than new mutants, which was another run of the X-Men.
That's just like, it features different X-Men in it, but the X-Men, because that's, it's trickier than Spider-Man, right?
Spider-Man's one dude.
He's whether it's spectacular or amazing.
Oh yeah. Yeah. He's not always one dude.
That's true. But for the most part, he was one dude throughout the history of things.
Yeah. And then with the X-Men, it's like, this isn't like the Fantastic Four, because there's still always just four of them.
The X-Men is like, you know, mutants in general are considered X-Men in this world.
And so, uh, the number of X-Men, I think at one point was really large.
And then, uh, I think it was like over 600 or whatever.
And then they did like a, a big comic book event like they do every year.
And they did one where they just like killed like half or almost all of the mutants thanks to, um, Wanda.
Oh, that's great.
The Scarlet Witch. Hmm.
Yeah. Well, it's particularly confusing, the uncanny thing to me, because nowhere in this game that I could find, does it say uncanny X-Men.
That's true. Even the title screen just says Marvel's X-Men.
Yeah, it's just on the box, I think.
Oh, yeah. I think it was in the manual.
I didn't actually look at the box art.
But I feel like the uncanny X-Men, uh, thing, like, like that's good branding, right?
Like to, because that's what the comic book was probably being referred to around that same time.
So it'd be like calling a game Spider-Man and not the amazing Spider-Man.
Like the, the most popular comic series for Spider-Man was, and still is, the amazing Spider-Man.
That'd be a real amateur move.
Be like, I don't get it.
Is this game not uncanny?
I guess my point is that, like, what, you know, what, the, the PS4 Spider-Man, that's called Marvel's Spider-Man, correct?
It would be like if the box said Marvel's Spider-Man, but then the title screen just said Spider-Man.
I'm looking at my box right now, and I think it just says Marvel's Spider-Man, yeah.
Yeah, but I think that's what the title screen says too, right?
True that. Right. So you have a branding issue right off the bat on the titles.
Bad game. Yeah. That, you're just not going to let them walk away from that.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kind of confusing, though, that they're called the X-Men at all, right?
We've been saying X-Men, X-Men, X-Men, but even issue number one had Marvel Girl, who's not in this game, but she's a woman.
I don't know. They tried to demean her and call her just a girl, but, you know, where's my X-Women representation?
Why is it X-Men?
I feel like it's just more of a, it just sounds better as a word than, like, X-Citizens?
X-People. X-People, X-Citizens.
Yeah, I mean, I'm assuming that the men was coming from, like, the sort of, like, dated version of men, which was referring to just, like, mankind.
Yeah, like, you know, human.
It doesn't really use much anymore, but.
X-Men. Maybe it's just, like, X-Men.
Well, you know, it's interesting, because comics of this time period, the early 60s, you know, they had women superheroes like Marvel Girl and Miss Invisible on the Fantastic Four.
But even Miss Invisible, like, she, she's, like, still relegated to doing, like, the chores for the Fantastic Four as well.
Like, she's still responsible to, like, clean the headquarters.
And they, like, talk about it.
Storm wasn't in the original X-Men run, so I don't know if they ever were misogynistic towards her later on in the run, but.
Well, I'm sure, you know, law of averages.
Right, right. But Storm was not in original X-Men.
And the original X-Men, I think I could try to get them off the top of my head, but Cyclops, Angel, Marvel Girl.
I feel like, is it Iceman?
What is that guy's name?
It's, like, an Iceman.
Yeah, Iceman. At least that's what it is in the game.
Yeah, and one other.
But who knows what it is on the cover.
No, it is Iceman.
It is Iceman. I know.
And then one other that I can't remember, but people are going to yell at me.
They're Nightcrawlers. I'm just cheating.
I'm looking at the issue. It's Beast.
Oh, you're talking about the comic.
Yeah, the original run.
Yeah, sorry. Right now.
Okay. We're still just talking about the comic, but if we want to move over to the game, that's fine.
No, no, no. I'm down to keep talking.
I like to learn things.
Do you have a favorite X-Men?
I got more Sears stuff.
You know, I think I'm pretty basic, and I'm a Wolverine fan.
Maybe I'm just a Hugh Jackman fan, though.
Like, I don't really know how much of Sony's X-Men.
Is it Sony? It's Sony, right?
Whoever makes the X-Men movies.
Fox. Yeah, them.
I don't know how much of Hugh Jackman's performance was inspired by the actual Wolverine of the comics, but I like him.
I'm kind of not super familiar with most X-Men stuff, so most of my knowledge is from maybe the one Fox movie that I saw, or the two Fox movies that I saw, and from anything in the MCU that's starting to reference.
So I don't have much to pull from.
I mean, Wanda? I don't know.
I think Magneto has a pretty cool reason to be evil.
I think he's a pretty well-rounded villain.
That's true, yeah. And how much longer is the Magneto villain thing going to make sense?
You know, like, we're so far away from World War II now.
He's just going to have to be really, really old if they want to keep that going.
Well, he could be frozen on ice or something, like Captain America.
That's a good idea.
Let's do that. Done.
When I buy Disney.
I'm easy. I'm a fan of Cyclops.
I just like the idea that he just wears, like, as a kid, I didn't even think it was a power.
I thought it was just sunglasses that he wore that shot out those beams.
And I was like, oh, that's cool.
Anybody could be Cyclops.
Like, Spider-Man, impossible for me.
I'd have to be bit by a spider.
Cyclops, I just put on some cool headgear.
That raises the question, though, like, of Cyclops' pre-visor.
Like, when he was born, did he have this power?
Like, did he kill the doctor that delivered him?
And, like, things like that.
Like, I don't know.
I want to see that origin story.
I'm sure it's Hans' diz.
Cyclops, year one.
Give us the birth of Cyclops.
in the uncanny x-men video game you do get to play as cyclops as well as i think sean was kind
of rounding them out for me but it's wolverine colossus nightcrawler cyclops storm and ice man
sorry and um you you choose your x-man superhero and uh also choose an ai or i have a second player
choose their superhero to enter any stage of your choosing so it's kind of like megaman but not
really uh you enter a level you clear the area of constantly spawning enemies in these levels as
you try to get closer and closer to the super villain at the end of the stage all levels are
played in this like top down zelda dungeon style with you and your um partner x-man in the in the
stage i think the most interesting part of the x-men are their unique powers so guys how unique
does each character feel well there's like the two powers right what the next one yeah what do you
mean yeah yeah those who can punch those who can punch and those who can punch do they punch is that
what they're doing that's like you know yeah some some like swipe at you like that i yeah all the x-men
are either swipers or spewers um and so basically in the game there are two attacks there's some of the
x-men can uh shoot a a vaguely themed projectile uh at an enemy or they can just sort of lunge and
like presumably punch um if they don't have lasers that come out of their eyes or ice cubes that are
generated from their chest or something um and that's that those are the weapons yeah and it kind
of it kind of adds adds fire to that age-old debate of what's more powerful a weapon that you can fire
at someone from a distance out of harm's way or uh not doing that
some would say that there's more honor in sort of just vaguely swiping at someone
right right yeah but it is yeah it is you know i did not see um much of a reason to ever choose a
character that didn't have a projectile weapon but i'm not an honorable i get it but like wolverine for
instance is a is an x-man who would i x-man i'm making him like singular now um i don't know what
the singular is i'm just gonna roll with it and say that they're x-men even if they're talking about
them singularly so wolverine would just attack with his claws so in this game they've made it so that
uh whether it looks like he's attacking with his claws or not it's melee combat for him and colossus
would attack with his fist i suppose he's really strong uh and so it looks like exactly the same thing
and doesn't basically the difference between playing wolverine or colossus it means nothing
it just it's like style points for you whether you like a certain character more yeah i mean there
are some vague stats he's probably faster like wolverine's probably faster right right and we can
talk about it's hard to see the difference yeah in in the game um but uh nightcrawler who is also
melee he at least they like gave the um the teleportation thing where he can just walk through
walls to simulate the idea of him teleporting like that actually feels like a step in the right
direction of making a character feel unique because it even comes at the expense of hit points so you
know like they like i feel like there's got to be at least one thing that they could have done that
only like colossus can do to the environments like he could break the walls yeah yeah shake things or
something right but they didn't do that they didn't or like couldn't couldn't i mean isn't wolverine's
whole thing he like regenerates couldn't he just like slowly regain health right i think that just gave
him more health yeah yeah but i like your idea joe just because yeah he is immortal um in that sense
but i mean right right but yeah i actually didn't know about uh what is it nightcrawler i didn't even
know about his special power and i did try to play as everybody um but you know i must have just not
realized that i could walk through walls when i played as him i don't think i played as him for
very long you were just respecting the boundaries right i was like i know what the developers wanted
here i don't want to yeah well yeah that's exactly what it looks like too though joe it's not uh it
doesn't have a cool effect you just walk through the environment uh it doesn't it's just to pretend
the idea of teleportation because they couldn't figure out how to let a character teleport in this
game uh cyclops storm and ice man are the projectile um people however cyclops is the weakest of the
batch because he can only do uh projectile combat storm and ice man get the ability to fly and i get it
like ice man must be like flying via the snow that he's generating and riding like an avalanche or
something um yeah but storm i don't know like you know that makes sense uh for her for sure to to fly
and also she she shoots like lightning bolts instead of the laser beams that cyclops shoots out uh and
then it kind of just looks like fire but i i mean they describe it as lightning so i'll i'll take we're
being nice yeah and that's that's how these characters uh feel and you know joe you were
saying like you know the stats might be different and everything but i don't know if it's just the
amount of enemies in this game or whatever but it didn't feel like um the difference between wolverine
and colossus meant anything uh through my you know a bit limited play testing with them yeah i mean i i
agree i mean i think that i believe that the stats are different because they say they are i don't
believe it because i experienced any difference like like i think that you all like you get you get
you pick up health so frequently there are just so many enemies you kill them really pretty easily as
anyone that you are apparently there are some speed differences but you never really need to move
that fast or anything i mean there's a couple times you gotta like get through a sliding door quickly or
something but like i don't know if like your speed stat really contributes too much to that like one
step you need to do um so yeah like i'm sure that there's like some damage calculation happening where
it's like your projectile is more powerful but like most enemies die in like one or two hits anyways
so i don't know i i never really felt the difference between anything yeah i also um there's a there are
so there's speed strength uh i forgot what the other two are but one of them is willpower
power endurance speed and willpower yeah i don't know what willpower is supposed to signify um it if
it has to do with like maybe you take less damage then i don't know maybe just give that person more hp
i i don't know like i did you get do you guys know what willpower is i should but i remember actually
making a mental note of like i gotta look that up um i did read through the i mean admittedly i
wasn't like super thorough and reading the manual but i don't remember seeing it even in the manual
i think they just listed them these are the four right that's what i was gonna say sean is like i'm
i'm not sold that because yeah you're right joe they're not listed in the manual i you know i went
back and even checked like game faqs to see if like the guide on there says like what these hidden
stats could mean it's not even mentioned at all um so i wonder if this is like one of those marvel.com
things where uh people get really upset about this where they give like a power scale to every marvel
character that's ever existed and when you're ranking like 2 000 characters you're bound to just have
like erroneous eras where it's like uh you know spider-man's power is a seven and hulk's is a nine it's
like spider-man would get lit up by hulk like two power points isn't even like that big of a difference
and those are made up i'm just saying like there's many examples of stuff like that i wonder
if this is just for creative flair of like what their stats could be uh based on like you know the
to give them some building without actually building it out into the gameplay i will state that i did
feel a difference with speed so at least speed i feel that is a real thing uh those differences
but yeah the one that the willpower i don't even know what it means so i don't know how to prove that
some players just give up if they have low willpower then the ai computer just stop it describes you
yeah yeah
uh it's two players always because the x-men are always a team right uh you can't just be one x it's not the wolverine game uh we'll play that one i think that they
i think that they also don't know how to like singularize x-men so i just always make sure there's
they just dodge that conversation they didn't want to ask they didn't want to ask stan lee at the time
they were like right we say x-man like probably not um no no but but it brings up a good point of like
you know when you have a team idea in in modern games there would be like some kind of like puzzle
solving of like the you know teaming up these two characters means that the gameplay is going to play
different than if you were storm and and uh nightcrawler right but instead it's just kind of
like you're tied down to this ai player if you don't have a friend or you know you're tied down to your
friend's choice too but the ai one has the ability to like get stuck uh and just end the game for you
basically softlock itself where it can't figure out how to move around the wall and uh that's like a
that's just a huge problem that like you know i'm in my experience of playing this game i ran into
it in my first 15 minutes so i can't imagine play testers didn't notice that this could happen
and so you have to play like with nightcrawler to really guarantee that that won't happen because at
least he can teleport through the walls oh you know what i didn't even think of that but
yeah it seems like whatever they did with with this ai model like it is it's just way too
rudimentary and maybe if every screen was just a like a field of enemies with no obstacles like
maybe it would work then uh even though i've seen uh the ai completely glitch out and just start
walking back and forth shooting projectiles over and over like many times like within the first
30 seconds of playing um maybe it would happen less but they you know they didn't want it to be
a complete bore so they made you have to walk around things but their ai does not know how to do that
but yeah i guess nightcrawler fixes that yeah i mean i was initially kind of like before i played it
when i just kind of saw what was going to happen a little impressed because i couldn't remember
like what other games have we played in the nes that had an ai companion no i can't think of one
have we yeah i feel like that was like i was like a surprise that that was that that was um
happening you know that was doable then i it made sense once i booted it up and it just doesn't work
but but at first i was like wow that's pretty ambitious for the nes and i don't know really
anything about coding uh video games and stuff but i i know that like for enemies it's usually a um
like a heat seeking missile kind of thing where it knows your placement and just the enemies behave a
little bit randomly but they also know where you are and try to like shoot at you or or move towards
you in this game you can see that happening but because like walls are in the way it's kind of funny
that sometimes even enemies will act like really stupid and just like hug the side of a wall thinking
that they're shooting their projectiles at you but they just constantly repeat them into a wall
at infidium until you come to them but the ai does that too so really it's like you're tagging along with
um it's like a rescue mission thing you know where you just have to like hope that uh your ai character
survives alongside you i don't think you're penalized if they die though like you can just
play on without them but uh that's hoping that they die and not and don't get stuck
if you can kill one type of enemy you can kill them all there's there's different sprites for enemies
but the idea is just attack the enemy and or shoot the projectile at the enemy and then it dies
that nothing behaves differently in this game it's just kind of like a smorgasbord of ideas of not
even things that i recognize from the comics or anything i'm not really sure you know you could
you could complain about the constantly respawning enemies you could complain about the designs of the
enemies i think the most boring thing is just that the behavior of the enemies and how you just have
to kind of like deal with them is the worst part of this game if they were if they were fun to fight
that that'd be a different story i i'd say yeah the only difference like this there are different
sprites and those different sprites move slightly differently and then you've got some that are
different shapes like you got little snakes that run around but only their head is a hitbox i think so
uh they may as well just be uh um uh just be another like single square wide thing um and i guess like
yeah i mean i mean it's not like that it's all just like palette swapped but there really isn't any
difference in terms of their strength or uh how hard they are to kill it's it's pretty boring and i
don't know if that comes down to just the repetitiveness of it doesn't matter like really
which x-men you are because you know because you can only either shoot your projectile or or hit them
i don't know if that's what makes it boring but i'm thinking about this game as like something where
it doesn't really matter like what you're you might as well just dodge everything and keep moving forward
uh to get to the boss because these enemies they're just like in your way they're not really like
causing much harm right yeah well it's it's not even for me it's not even like moving forward like
the moving forward part even like i i kind of started doing what you're saying is like i kind
of stopped paying too much attention to the enemy unless they were in my way or i needed health which
was an easy way to just get more health but moving forward is even like not super clear like i feel
like there's this aimlessness to the to the to the whole game as a whole like in general where i'm like
i don't know i mean i guess i could go this way and like no you can't but there's no wall there you
can't go there there's a wall here but you can go through that one like or you know you can go past this
part like i'm just like i don't it's not it doesn't feel like a dungeon or a puzzle or a maze it
just feels like a mess yeah i wasn't sure for most of this game where i was supposed to go
and so then i thought okay maybe it's a like you have to kill a certain amount of enemies and it's
sort of like a like it's a clear of the stage and then i ended up just doing that for a while and then
i ended up stepping on a uh some kind of sprite that was supposed to be some kind of entrance
or something and i went somewhere else and like oh okay maybe i'm making progress and then i did that
for a while and didn't know where the hell i was um i eventually made it to a boss um but i didn't know
how i got there i didn't know how to get back yeah well that's the other thing i mean in the manual
it gives you your objective which is like get to the boss beat the boss whatever and then get out
but like getting even the beginning of the stage is just like you just get to a spot and it's like
all right you won it's not even like a door you have to get out you're just like oh that's the spot
there's nothing marking it or anything like i guess you have to remember exactly the spot you started in
but like they're big stages so it's like it just the whole thing feels aimless i'm thinking about
another team-based game we had teenage mutant ninja turtles and not that we were like fond of that game
uh or you know maybe we weren't as harsh as people might have expected us to be but that game kind of
made the turtles feel at least a little bit different with the way that their weapons were
and you you live swap them as opposed to like being forced to like drag donatello through the stage you
could just choose to be like now i'm gonna be donatello or now i'm gonna be raphael and mostly that
was just to manage your health and uh make sure you like you know continued on but you know that's a
game where too there's like the idea of just going across a level to level and finding the the end
point but it didn't feel as obtuse as this and i don't know if that's because that game was a
side-scrolling platformer where things were maybe laid out a little clearer or more what we're used to
and this top-down thing uh specifically in like that space level i don't even know if it's space or
not but um i think i think the difference between this game and that game like despite the the the most
obvious things of like yeah it's a side scroller things a little bit more clear with that and uh
uh it was less of a hassle that you didn't have to deal with a a dumb ass ai uh companion i i think
what was different with the ninja turtles was it had a an idea of visual language and you kind of knew
like what was a hazard where you were supposed to go what was walkable and what wasn't right this this
space level that i was talking about um i guess like a ship that you're on it's very unclear like
what's walkable because some things are like transparent other things yeah like even what's
a door and what's not as weird in this one because there's like blue circles and red circles and
squares and like those things are the doors i'm like what this is almost like a like a
it not an mc escher it it feels like a collage of of like mismatched patterns that like it has an
idea of oh this one's always going to be the floor and this one's always going to be the wall but like
either the whatever the the difference is in the actual programming of the game of like oh this is
like the nav mesh and yeah this is the art for it like they were misaligned or something what it feels
like to me to be honest is that like you have glitched out of a of a like 2d you know like a
game like this but like you you know and you glitch out of like a final fantasy game or like a pokemon
game you get like a glitch city or something and it's just like oh the textures and tiles are all over
the place that like exist in the code but they were not placed here by humans yeah
according to the back of the box and uh i i read this uh it's up to you to defeat magneto
but of course that's if you can ever find him uh the game only gives you the five stages
and it's not as simple as beating all five stages like you would in say mega man and then
you know dr wily reveals himself now dr magneto reveals himself that that's not what happens here
instead you're supposed to put together that at the end of each of these stages the like
congratulations thing that you've um that you receive at the end of each stage is giving you like
bits and pieces of a code that when you put those code words together across the
the five levels you would then realize like oh i need to look at the box
of my game like the the box i bought with this game which has the remaining pieces of the code
and then you put the code together for that and input that into the menu screen and that's how you
unlock the magneto level are they asking way too much there were clues on the box on the on the box
uh sorry not on the box uh on the cartridge right oh yeah it's it's on the cartridge i believe um and
it tells you uh it tells you the code that you get through the game tells you to like look at the um
to look at the now i can't remember if it's the cartridge of the box you got me questioning
but wait a minute the code how do you get this code it's code words that are on
at the end of each level so say you beat the scarlet witch um yeah not scarlet witch the white queen
uh say you beat the white queen level there's a message there and then there's code words in that message
so you just take those pieces of that code word now this is too much like yeah there's no way that anyone
like is either going to i mean yeah people could probably sink some hours into this game if they
were if they really had nothing better else to nothing better to do but the lateral thinking that
you need to have like to figure this out is too much without a guide or like just something in the
manual or why even have it locked behind a code i don't know yeah that's yeah i mean if i guess if
it's like i mean i can understand the like the attraction to doing something like that like oh
this is so cool and unique and interesting because it like brings in something physically in the real
world and whatever but like it doesn't make for it doesn't really make any like difference in world
than just having like okay you beat all these bosses you've unlocked it like i get that they're trying
to make it like a puzzle or like something you have to figure out and you'll be satisfied for
figuring out but that's just because like in in the most famous use of this uh metal gear solid
right uh it the game literally tells you look on the back of the box snake look on the back of the box
or something along those lines in this like is it is it being clear like that or is it just words that
you're supposed to put together and then maybe figure out it's also on the box like mike do you
know i do give me a second though because i want to read the exact code but i do know that it does tell
you to look at the cartridge um okay but i want to have the exact code um also i've never played uh
metal gear solid but yeah i am aware of that uh puzzle and i'm never sure i mean you're you're a fan
sean i mean how how how is that received uh i mean it's pretty clear that uh on the box it's a it's
like a a scene that doesn't actually happen the game and the the screenshot it's like a screenshot
showing parts of the game and it's just snake saying meryl and you're trying to figure out the
frequency for meryl and there it is uh what once you're like like oh maybe i should look at the box
then you find it right but i guess i mean how was that received by fans like a lot of people think
it's really clever and they liked it yeah i guess i could see it being clever but also i mean again i
mean metal gear solid is a very story driven game i feel like i would just be totally like
taken out of it be like well yeah but what's the context within the world of what i'm looking at
that that is true i guess when i was uh a young lad context was uh the nuance of context wasn't
that important to me yeah there okay so it gets crazier than what i was describing right because what
happens yeah what happens in the game all right is let's say you beat the juggernaut okay it it shows
you on the screen in all white text you managed to break through juggernaut's screen of defenders
by pushing constantly towards your objective you have beaten the enemy once again time to select a
new challenge and test your fighting ability but according to um to the cutting room floor
certain parts of that text were supposed to be read and this was the information that i was given so
that's why um i didn't realize that it's not because i didn't remember right so it's the same text okay
the same thing i just read to you guys but instead the red parts which were the code words were screen
by pushing select end and if you took all of the um hidden messages across battle through a living starship
the subterranean confrontation all these levels you would get the last mission can be reached from
the mission screen by pushing select and seek the advice of the l from leader and then able is spelt a
b e l so that it would be label from two different words the l in leader and able from another section
able to make it to the final mission so you have to uh push you know select i like this more you have
to push select and then you go to the cartridge label and it just says in the bottom right over by
where the um over by where all the copyright info is it says plus b plus up um together uh on start
i kind of like this actually no this is so stupid i remember this is i remember seeing the red text i
kind of like it in the sense that it's it's you would think like you would think like okay there's
something weirder because i did think i also remember noticing that abel is spelled yes abel
is spelled wrong because it's trying to make label um i still don't know if i understand why
contextually the x-men are solving this puzzle yeah like is there a riddler equivalent that's what
bothers me but like it's not as it's not as uh ridiculous of an idea that someone would figure
this out as i had they should have made it so that you put a magnet up against your television
and that the certain uh image quality screens would change and that would cause you to understand what
you have to do next yeah it would also ruin your tv yeah yeah but that's okay yeah i also sell tvs
maybe the listeners don't but yeah context still bothers me and the fact that you probably just
you know i mean for most of the rest of history most people probably won't have the original label
so i mean i don't know how long how much of a longevity they thought this game was gonna have but
that bothers me but i i i want to like walk back my initial uh hate for the idea about at least it
being like impossible because i think that um this would be something that someone could figure out
because there's they're pretty clearly words that you're meant to look at you know what i'm keeping
it but uh my reasoning is only kojima can do it i just think it's crazy um that it requires how many
special enemies which i didn't even i didn't even think there were special enemies in the stage
it's not even something i was actively like keeping track of but by killing 30 special enemies in a
stage that's what causes the correct text to be displayed red the keywords okay well also i missed
that too that i don't like that either no but i'm saying like so think about you could beat the level
and the text would either be all white or it would be like oh you because you killed 30 special enemies
something that is like you know in super mario brothers when you land on an even number that
many number of fireworks happen right like that's something fun and cute and happens right there the
payoff is over this is something where it's like well they never told me like in the manual like make
sure you kill 30 special enemies or anything or even explained why i was getting red text this time
but then you also have to like because these levels aren't in a particular order or whatever like
because you get to choose what if you get them in like a different order and then you have to like
now think about which order they come in to understand the the hidden message um this is i i don't think
this is smart at all joe but i i get what you're saying it's very innovative look i the the reason
the the part about the part about this that i agree on you agree with you on is like i guess more
that like yeah i do think that it's just too missable it's too easy like there's nothing there's nothing
telling you that you should be looking for something like that so you miss the first two
it's like what you gotta play the whole game again to to get to that like that's annoying i guess i'm
just saying that i don't think it's as um i think as a puzzle i like it i don't i don't like the way
it's integrated or it being integrated in this game i have a question uh about something else it's it's
more so about uh controlling gosh i hope we can answer it we had a hard enough time getting through
this magneto thing yeah um the thing i i feel like we've settled that right yeah yeah um what is
jumping for yeah i don't know yeah i i'm not quite sure um i thought i thought that like when i was
storm and i was flying around that i was gonna be like able to dodge enemies and stuff like that
but you can't you can't i feel like you go a little faster when you're flying but like okay but
there's still a jump button i know they can't fly i just want to know like is there a point is it
just so that they could use another animation frame sean it's a video game you jump in video games it's
just the way it's done yeah it doesn't matter like there's no actual utility in jumping but you have to
have a jump button how often do you jump in real life i'm not very you can't this is true but you
know in a platforming game or a side scrolling action game like tmnt you jump an awful lot because
that's the way that the stages are designed these stages are not designed for jumping so you know
like the only thing they would be useful for is for uh dodging enemies or or jumping over enemies um
in in that regard i guess but again i don't know why you would have to do that right i i i thought at
one point that like no matter who you were when you jump you got like a boost of speed so i tried to
jump through some of those aforementioned like doors that were closing quickly that you had to
get through but i don't think that really made a difference either i just can't believe that that
like just closing doors is one of the defining features of this game like there's doors that close
i feel like that's probably the thing that will kill you the most yeah and because it because i feel
like this game doesn't have any iframes it's just if you make contact with a thing that deals damage
it will just continue to deal damage until you blow up but that is something oh that leads me to
something else that i wanted to talk about how do you know that even you you your your health isn't
on screen you have to pause the game to check your health and that's crazy which like fine not the end
of the world but this is like it seems like this is better played as a two-player game which i didn't
do but if you play this as two-player you're just constantly both pausing it in the middle of the
action like without you know you gotta like i'm gonna pause it now like hold on i'm gonna unpause
it now like it's just it's just weird and you can't tell you can't tell if you're about to die
unless you pause it you're just constantly pausing and unpausing bizarre was there anything that we
loved about this game special shout outs to the sprites maybe the uh no they're all everything's
everything's so ugly uh no those are ugly too yeah wolverine's cross-eyed everyone it looks like
everyone got slammed and they had to they all got mug shots and they were yeah they were still
plastered at the at the uh at the police station and this is them this is the lowest point of these
superheroes lives and that's this is like the scene in guardians of the galaxy where they're all
getting like yes it's that um i also thought the sprites for some reason the sprites were reminding
me so much of a long forgotten nes game muscle yeah dot u dot s dot c dot l dot e whatever we call it
yeah there's a uh a putty like a putty like texture to all of the characters that muscle yeah
and yeah they're all kind of like squat and like you know and and there's you know i don't i haven't
played muscle in a very long time but i do vaguely remember feeling uh like the power sets of those
or power the ability sets like where didn't feel different or unique enough and and i felt maybe that's
also why i was thinking of it with x-men uncanny x-men so it's not beautiful it's not that fun
it's a little confusing how to beat the game any any points about the music uh it kind of sounded like
digitized nails on a chalkboard yep that sounds about right
so what's the future of x-men look like on this uh on this console let's take it to the sequels and
spinoff section and let's talk about wolverine but let's talk about it in like 200 episodes when
we get there because that's coming to the nes in 1991 and it's not another top-down game as wolverine
this is a side-scrolling action game so we got a chance for um some of our notes to be addressed
that said i don't think this game sucks because it's top-down right it's just that oh i agree yeah
it just sucks because there's um you're not really feel like you're playing as the x-men i feel like i'm
playing as four or five video game sprites yeah and what we wanted to happen or like you know things
that we were talking about with like tmnt that like we thought that i did more right than this
like could have been accomplished in in a top-down setting could have been done like this where it's
like there's a sense of place and and you know your characters have slightly different slight
differences to them and you're not stuck waiting for an ai character and all that stuff like you know
it's not like it's not like that's all like uh byproducts of it being top-down so so yeah i
don't even want to give it that like that out no that that that's not an excuse not an excuse for
this game but if you really want to feel like you're uh the x-men and you're the x-men as a team
obviously you would want to play the x-men arcade game that came out in uh i believe it was 92
uh and that's the one where you can play as many as six people can be the x-men all at once and this
is like right up there with the the simpsons arcade game they're both made by konami um konami just makes
great games back then but then you also have um what else uh x-men legends right was that game that
was on like the gamecube ps2 era that has like a bunch of x-men so yeah you can't play like six people
at once but you can be all the x-men and stuff like that and run around and do all sorts of cool
shit in that game uh i'm sure there's like many other wolverine games there's that x-men uh uh what's
that the one for genesis that's really popular oh x-men 2 clone wars i'm not sure what x-men 1 was
but x-men 2 clone wars is considered it's probably this uh yeah uh maybe it was this uh sure uh no
it looks like it was children of the atom which is a fighting game though so no that's not true
see why am i getting led in the wrong direction by moby games why are they doing that to me
shout out to moby games that is it x-men children of the atom has an interesting history because
uh that is like the one that started the whole like x-men street fighter marvel versus capcom
thing oh yeah so uh in 1994 x-men children of the atom was made by capcom
and then the success of that fighting game would go on to them uh lead to x-men versus street fighter
and then they were like wait why are we just doing two games why don't we do marvel versus capcom uh and
so that's how these did that whole like thing kind of evolved and then uh marvel versus capcom
infinite i think was the one that like killed the franchise so hopefully it comes back eventually but
we don't have it as of right now there are 52 x-men games though so i can't just like
do it just keep going i can't do a true sequels and spin-off section right i would have thought that
you would have kept it to like uncanny x-men 2 on the nes that will play in three weeks or something
right right it only came out like it's only like the third next game that came out after this one
uh yeah only one other x-men game that we're playing on the nes and that's wolverine otherwise
a lot of the x-men movies wind up becoming um games based off of the movies which i think is
interesting too like x-men the official game x-men last stand x-men origins wolverine
uh that was i guess a time when they were just making every movie was getting a video game
yeah i feel like the whole fox uh x-men run was you know the movie run was like
right in that time where everything got a game i mean like series of unfortunate events had a video
game this just in the x-men legends games that i was raving about earlier they got engaged
they got engaged versions can you imagine that like that's a really like we should play that that's
interesting because you you you can't have the same graphic that you have on ps2 you have to
completely rebuild that game with like sprites they probably hired some really cheap studio out of
some eastern european country to put it together and they were never heard from again uh yeah it was
developed by barking lizards so you're probably right never never heard of them
anyway um something you guys have all heard of and uh you probably seem tired of hearing it by now
but even if we didn't hide it this episode we have to do the essential games list
sean your vote for the uncanny x-men uh yeah there really are no bright spots
yeah there's no redeeming factors this is just a terrible game uh that doesn't live up to its
namesake and even though i have no real reference except for some movies uh in the past 15 20 years
so yeah it's just really bad not essential this is a very simple and repetitive game but it's not
even easy like it's a pretty tough game you know like you gotta really like slog through you gotta
have high willpower stats of your own to really like want to play through this game i don't feel
like i'm the x-men while playing this game which is the bare minimum they should have hoped to
accomplish when making when you make any kind of intellectual property at least want to make it feel
like you're engaging as those characters you couldn't tell me wolverine was in this game other than
that cross-eyed portrait so no not essential he was drunk he was he made some mistakes mike
um i'm actually gonna bounce off what you said there a little bit too because my biggest thought
like i said i'm not super familiar with x-men but the one thing i know about is that they all have
very unique and interesting powers and i think like the biggest crime you could commit when making
an x-men game is making it feel like you didn't you couldn't tell if you were playing as wolverine
or you couldn't tell if you were playing as ice man like they're all so unique if you and you have
such a such a large pool of characters to pull from i mean it's it's weird to me that like everybody
felt so bland and like samey uh and that's just my like major like first thing that jumps out to me
flaw obviously there are a lot of other flaws that you know that the levels were kind of an eyesore i mean
i don't need to rehash it all also not a sense not essential so hopefully this black friday we helped
you save a ton of time by not playing the uncanny x-men and instead listening to us of course the
savings are always there when you tune into nostalgia um but technically not with time because it requires
time to listen to us so trust us the savings are in there somewhere joe where are the savings what's
the savings are because normally when you want this information you want to sit down and watch a video
or play a game you got to sit down and commit to it you can do this while you're doing the dishes
you know you're multitasking you know you're you're you're on a drive you can listen to this you know
you're you're learning our opinions while doing something else rather than having to have a conversation
with us yeah we saved you from the experience of playing uncanny x-men unless you chose to listen to
this after playing it yourself in which case we may have like triggered some kind of vietnam flashback
and we're sorry if we did that but there are no refunds there's no no refunds no coupons accepted
either don't tweet us coupons yeah yeah coupons are very not cash money this is not a discount podcast
consume uncanny x-men don't forget too that uh our patreon subscribers were able to listen to this a
whole day early that's right they got to listen to this on thanksgiving while they were sitting with
their family at the table instead of listening to what's going on in little billy's life they got to
just turn this on and be like you know uh alexa play nostalgia and i bet that works i bet if you uh
if you ran a plug-in or something i bet that works and i bet i just turned on your alexa by saying alexa
right alexa but our patreon subscribers are also going to get uh a nostalgia bites episode very soon
just like they get every month so you're gonna want that too that is the just in time for christmas
kid dracula game oh yep only came to the very festive so yep and the nightmare before christmas if you
would get your eggnog ready punks right throw out those leftovers and carol on down to nostalgia town out